[Music]
first of all welcome to how the light
gets in festival thank you i'm very
happy to be here you started out as a
practicing psychotherapist and then you
switched to philosophy what made you
shift careers
um
i'm not sure if i ever actually took a
decision to shift careers
i mean yeah i'm not i'm not practicing
anymore since i started my phd
but in some way
psychoanalysis or psychotherapy has
always been in the background
of my philosophy work yeah so i work on
the philosophy of psychoanalysis
both both in forms of philosophy informs
my thinking of of psychotherapy and
psychotherapy and my history in
psychotherapy but also my
reading of
especially freud and lacan inform my
understanding of
issues in philosophy
and of course there are a few other
philosophers whose work sort of spans
both fields
two people come to mind jonathan lear uh
cornelius castoriadis another greek
philosopher apart from there being sort
of philosophical questions around
psychoanalysis is there
a sort of deeper connection between the
two thing are they related in any way
yeah i think there's an obvious
connection which is the subject matter
the human being
so i think that what
khan calls the central question of
philosophy what is a human being and
it's it's three aspects of
what can i know what all i do what may i
hope for
are very much and should be in the heart
of
any investigation of the psyche
i think that's the
that's the obvious connection
philosophy and language philosophy of
language and the experience of
astonishment are two of your key areas
of interest at least in your earlier
work
you also have experience working with
children in this context so what did
that teach you about
language and astonishment and you know
how has that experience affected your
your work in philosophy
i'm so glad you asked that question
because the
topic of children or
talk of children
is something that is really missing in
philosophy and i think that's for
obvious reasons that have to do with
what it has meant to do philosophy and
who has been doing philosophy
um
um so so i'm glad to say something about
that to be able to say something about
that i can't i can't think of any
particular ways
um in which it has like to give you
particular propositions but
um i think
it does
um
it does
make you more sensitive to the
complexity of what it means to be in the
world
because you know in philosophy we tend
to draw these very clear-cut
distinctions between the emotional life
and the life of the mind self-thinking
rationality
and then you have the body and bodily
sensations and then you have how do all
these things relate to others
but i think when you are looking at a
child
and their main way of being in the world
with
for example let's take the case of
playing
um it's it's impossible to draw these
distinctions that are so clear-cut in
the case of the adult
because the child when
while playing
the child is
thinking
uh is processing and
and
um uh exploring emotions and is also
connecting to others through the body
um yeah so i think it's a way to
um
to to make you more sensitive to that
complexity with some so often it's kind
of
lost in in philosophy
so in some ways philosophy is focused
too much on
the adult sort of mode of being when it
comes to like thinking of what it is to
be a human exactly but but i also think
it's important to bring in philosophy
when you look at the child
so recently and i think it may be
the first time definitely one of the few
times i saw
a remark on children in kierkegaard's
work the concept of anxiety it's just a
small short brief remark but what he's
saying there you know kiritiko has this
thing that that human beings are not
just a
body and psyche
but they are also spirit
and and he sees anxiety in children uh
which would ca
discusses as their
attraction to the enigmatic and the
monstrous as a sign of of spirit in
children so how the child is already a
case of the human being that we then
focus on in higher in terms of the
desire right
i thought that was beautiful
astonishment is is also a kind of weird
philosophical topic one that not many
people work on is that also a more
an experience that is more akin to kind
of being a child and being sort of
discovering the world
what sort of drew you to to study this
is somewhat neglected kind of yeah i
mean you're right that certain kinds of
astonishments
do
perhaps in its roots too i'm not sure i
haven't thought about that in relation
to children
but
my interest in astonishment was as
my entry point to a discussion about the
limits of language
and so i was interested in a particular
kind of wonder that i called
astonishment we could also call extreme
wonder
where that links to a difficulty of
expression in language so you
ordinarily when we speak of wonder we
think of things that are unusual curious
rare novelties
and in there you don't really have a
difficult expression because if you ask
me what is your wonder about and i say
to you well i just found out about the
quantum world and all this time i've
been living in the newtonian world and
that's
that that satisfies you and me in terms
of what is it
but when it comes to the examples i have
in mind like for example
um something that wickenstein mentions
the wonder of the existence of the world
that anything exists in the first place
you kind of knew that already you knew
that yesterday and the day before and a
few years ago so
why does this suddenly take on this
astonishing character and there you may
have a problem with with language and
the sense that there is something you
can't express
and i take a different position i think
expression is possible but that's my
way to say something about that
do you think all philosophy is a sort of
product of this kind of astonishment
that things that we've taken for granted
and we all assume we suddenly realize
their peculiarity or their weirdness or
the assumptions that lie behind it yeah
i mean there's this um
phrase in the theaters right that uh
philosophy originates in wonder
that socrates
says so i think you're very right that
that lies in the origin of philosophy
but of course there you've got an
interesting tension
again that has to do with what is that
wonder is it wonder like the one that we
find in science so is it kind of apporia
that can be solved by looking into
things or is it a different kind of
wonder that doesn't
um that doesn't connect to answerable
questions
as uh wonder does in the case of science
nature sort of is often something that
gives us
these kinds of experiences and you're
developing an interest in the
relationship between humans and nature
and the fact that we're kind of
increasingly losing a connection with it
and
how how is that affecting us and you
know what has what have we learned from
the past year of being
sort of maybe trying to reconnect with
nature as much as we can by going out in
parks and things like that
i think one danger always when one
talks about nature
is a romanticizing nature so in some
sense i think
nature has always been something that we
had to fight against
that we had to
shape so as to
survive
um
so
that was always the case but i think
there's something happening
with modernity and more specifically
with the
not just with technology but with the
spirit of technology and the spirit of
capitalism which is that nature like all
other things is just reduced to
um
what serves our narrow interests um like
heidegger says it becomes the standing
reserve just ready to exploit for for
things for profit i mean apart from the
very serious consequences like climate
change we all know that
um i think
it has a deeper kind of ethical
consequence too in terms of
losing this
relation to nature as other
and and um reducing it to something that
serves our interests and i think that's
something
important and perhaps with the i don't
know
i mean that's more of a sociological
perhaps
question like perhaps with the pandemic
there was a sense that something is lost
on that level and
need to return
to nature as this other
so that that's that's kind of moving in
a different direction from how some
people see it so some people argue that
well the the problem has been that we
see ourselves as separate to nature
nature is there for us to use and and
kind of
instrumentalize as as you say
and the solution to that is to
remind ourselves somehow that we're also
part of nature that we're we're also
natural beings and we're part of it and
therefore you know it nature is in this
other but do you think
in fact the right way to go is is not to
remind ourselves that we're also natural
but to kind of see nature as this kind
of other as you say i think i think
there is a way to respond to this by
bringing both the things that you just
um mentioned as
um
are as opposites to bring them in as two
sides of the same coin because i think
that
reminding
ourselves that we are
what i like to call earthlings earthly
creatures
is a reminder that we are
conditioned
and therefore that things are other to
us
and
that that
part of what it means to be conditioned
part of what
these conditions or this conditioning is
is the otherness of these of these
things that we have to respond to
yeah
we think of language as important in
terms of communicating our sort of
subjective psychological states our
experiences
and but at the same time we're trying to
do that through some kind of universal
system
in which we're trying to describe very
particular very unique types of
experiences
are the narratives that we give through
language always true to to those
experiences
i would want to say yes
but i would need to
[Music]
clarify or or make some of the words you
mentioned like the inner and and
language um
a bit more complex than we usually tend
to think
first of all perhaps also going back to
the case of the child i think that there
is a temptation to think of the inner
and the outer
as
to draw a very stark distinction between
the two
and then language becomes this tool of
translating what is inner to what then
is outer
but what that
fails to see is that the inner is
already intelligible
it is already shaped in a way that makes
it
uh intelligible to us and to others and
i'm thinking here of this psychoanalyst
beyond who looks into thinking and what
thinking is looks into babies and
mothers
and how the mother is the
thinking for the baby so that's what she
does she becomes
what maybe philosophy of mine they would
call the extended mind
of the baby and through that bond with
the baby she
thinks for the baby and makes things
intelligent
including itself including its own body
and what the baby is doing
for itself and for herself so i think
that's
so i think if we take that into account
and if we look at language as
more than just a tool for a presentation
then my answer would be yes
yeah so so language was already present
in the in the inner yeah
first nature second nature right yes
yeah
yeah
and what sort of
project are you working on currently
two projects i'm finishing a book on
wonder and anxiety as
encounters or experiences that can have
some kind of existential merit so that
can teach us something about the
possibilities of the human being
and i'm also just about to start a
project on nature that you mentioned
earlier
which looks into what we what it is that
we lose when we replace
real nature with man-made copies of
nature and of course the question that
comes
straight after what i just said is is
there such thing as real nature can we
even draw the distinction between real
and fake or or man-made so that these
are the new projects
you mentioned uh theaters earlier as a
dialogue by plato
being being greek and being a
philosopher do you find you have like a
special connection to the ancient greek
philosophical tradition do these texts
are these texts still alive for you do
you revisit them in your philosophical
projects
i think actually
greek
has done
two things it has impeded my relation to
this text
and enabled my relation to the texts it
has enabled it obviously through the
greek language and i feel more and more
grateful for the fact that i
learned ancient greek when i was as a
child and of course knowing
being a native
greek speaker also helps with that
but it has also impeded in the sense
that when something is so close to you
you tend to overlook it
um and i think it it it took some time
for me to
go back to what is close uh to home
and and i mean you probably also know
that that i think there's a strange
relation between greece and those and
those texts right now um
to to some extent they are treated more
as
things that you do in philology rather
than in philosophy so that's an added
difficulty
but god yeah i mean whether they
matter and how they matter i wouldn't
know
where to start i'll just say this how
how important and moving i find
that
it's not only that you find
thoughts that you yourself have
struggled with but that you find
thoughts
clearly expressed and i think one of the
things that
deeply moves me as a philosopher and
probably moves every philosopher
is to see
a clear thought because you know all the
work that has been done
and so when sometimes i read plato or
aristotle and i find that
just the idea that they have
that someone 2 000 years ago
has
done all the process that i am
struggling with
yeah that's astonishing
do you do you have a philosopher that
you think your views
mostly align with i mean to me it's not
so much a matter of
views because that's another discussion
nice topic of discussion i suppose
whether whether philosophy is about a
theory or about you
or whether it's about
a way of thinking
a method of thinking perhaps
and
when it comes to that
i think the two philosophies i've been
most
[Music]
influenced by and
that kind of speak to me most
is
wittgenstein and heidegger
wittgenstein because of the almost
relentless search for clarity
um which i really respect and admire
and also his way of looking into
looking into a philosophical problem by
looking at it rather than by
diving in
and heidegger because i think he's very
sensitive to how our existence is
conditioned
um
and
yeah i find him a very deep thinker in
relation to
to that
mario belasco thank you very much thank
you for your lovely questions
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the institute of art
and ideas at iai tv
[Music]